Haymaker Market it's happening at
Ferguson's downtown here to tell us all
about it is a curator Ashley zabardi
thank you so much for being here Ashley
thank you for having me this is such a
fun display and probably only just a
taste of what you can expect but tell us
a little bit about the Haymaker and what
we can expect to see when we shop there
so Haymaker Market is 100 handmade
everything you find there is going to be
made with locals hands which is really
exciting and fun everything's super high
quality we like craftsmanship and now we
are expanding into the Ferguson's alley
which is across the street from
Ferguson's and we are excited we're
going to have food trucks and kids
workshops and vendors and music it's
beautiful well it's going to be a party
down there and that's really exciting
that you guys are expanding you already
do so much at Ferguson's and now that
has to say something that you are
expanding across the street that's
really exciting and when I look at this
table when I walked over the first thing
I noticed were these huge cute
scrunchies is this something that you
can get at the market this is something
you can get in the Haymaker shop in
Ferguson's downtown so this is one of
our locals and she does do a lot of our
markets too so she is one of our vendors
I love it okay tell us a little bit else
about what's on the table here
everything is just so pink and colorful
and bright it makes me happy yeah so at
the director and I gave all the vendors
was bring something that we can show
everybody how you can shop local and
small for Valentine's Day whether that's
being for someone you love or yourself
so we have ceramics made by a local
artist photography silversmith jewelry
preserved flowers we've got lots of
these treats look how beautiful these
chocolates are oh my God aren't they
gorgeous they're cute you had me I guess
for myself yeah I'm like I'll take one
screen
what else we have over here what's this
beautiful artwork this blue piece this
is something we do in the shop so I
actually make these and they're all over
the shop I want to display a little bit
of how this shop looks we have lots of
organic shapes and lots of sculptural
elements in the shop that is stunning
that's also a caught my eye when I came
over so this is happening the weekend of
February 11th can people just come out
tell us the hours yeah so the market
runs 11 to 4 P.M come out we're gonna be
shopping and celebrating all weekend
shopping and celebrating I love it can I
try one of these screen yeah it's for
you I love everything about Ferguson's
downtown and I love that Las Vegas has
become more of a place for for local
businesses small businesses to grow and
Thrive so thank you for everything
you're doing be sure to check out the
market you can get us crunchy it's okay
you all right JC I'll send it over to
you I love